e
nadie sabe realmente lo que traerá el
próximo verano pero una cosa es segura a
la hora de vestir nos tendremos que
elegir entre dos grandes tendencias
presentadas en parís el skate wear o el
drapeado que escogerán yohji yamamoto o
prune goldsmith you live o coche fit el
coche se encuentra en el centro de un
movimiento llamado sweet future estas
prendas bastante cómodas que se pueden
usar en todas las situaciones son
trabajadas como en la alta costura pero
son menos intimidantes los cortes aunque
simples son muy estructurados y están
inspirados en los años 30 las cintas y
los encajes les dan un toque parisina
es una colección muy simbólica en
sintonía con la naturaleza porque diseñé
esta colección mirándola trabajando
frente al parque porque vivo muy cerca o
algo así como un regreso a las raíces un
regreso a lo artesanal con la elección
también de las telas casi la mitad de
las telas que ustedes son recicladas o
sostenibles orgánicas
y también hubo un gran trabajo de
bordado de plumas era importante hacerlo
y como modelos escogimos jóvenes que
encontramos en las calles de parís este
año dado el contexto y fue muy bonito
ver la energía de estos jóvenes
prendas tan diversas como los modelos
que las llevan decididos a desafiar las
ideas tradicionales sobre lo femenino y
lo masculino para existe el coche
organizar un desfile es un acto de
resistencia romántico y poético
genial es increíble me encanta este
desfile de moda al aire libre en el
parque ella es súper creativa me encanta
también se puede ver la influencia de la
calle creo que es algo que a ella
también le gusta ver las prendas en su
cotidianidad y eso les da una cierta
alegría bien me gusta mucho hay que
seguir viendo lo que hacen
ahora vamos a un almacén abandonado en
el sureste de parís para ver la
colección de lamin cuya té el más
parisino de los diseñadores africanos
estrella de la moda de los 90 su primera
colección fue completamente blanca usada
por chicas negras los vestidos muy
apretados eran fáciles de identificar
por sus costuras rojas su marca su nivel
significa abre bien los ojos en wolof lo
que intento hacer es rendir homenaje a
las mujeres esa es mi obsesión intento
rendirle tributo se ha sido siempre mi
objetivo y eso es lo que sigo tratando
de expresar pienso que las mujeres
necesitan ocupar el lugar que les
corresponde en todo este caos creo que
la solución no está ahí en la
colaboración y no en la explotación la
relación que tengo con mi madre con
todas las mujeres que me criaron me
enseñaron bueno ahí hay algo muy
positivo muy fructuoso
por cumplirse
cultivó el piso
cambiemos de ambiente de estilo y de
barrio el verdadero nombre de bruno
goldsmith es be gone y el icono de la
moda sonia rykiel la rebautizó como
frank y de ella también aprendió casi
todo sobre la moda hoy en día brum vive
en burdeos pero presenta su primera
colección en parís y esta es por cierto
su primera entrevista he estado
preparándome para hacer mi aparición
desde hace ya varios tiempo había estado
viviendo mi vida de mujer tengo cinco
hijos son mis creaciones más bellas pero
ya era hora de que hiciera otra cosa
necesitaba hacer un cambio drástico en
mi vida y ponerme al servicio de las
mujeres quería que se sintieran fuerzas
que se sintieran libres soy una mujer
extremadamente libre quiero que otras
mujeres se sientan libres y también que
inspiren respeto
spears le encanta jugar con los códigos
tradicionales de la sociedad burguesa y
eso no es lo único
y también está esta mujer atrevida que
se atreve a usar una gran blusa de seda
estampada con el kamasutra porque el
placer también forma parte del bienestar
en la vida porque no hablan del placer
sexual de la mujer mis mujeres pueden
estar tatuados perforadas lo que sea
porque me encanta todo eso pero siempre
son súper elegantes
los sitios class co bueno no podemos
hablar de elegancia sin mencionar a
yohji yamamoto que presenta su última
colección en el gran salón de eventos de
la alcaldía de parís
[Música]
siempre me ha atraído mucho lo que hace
es un verdadero visionario hace cosas
completamente excepcional es sé que
puede ser demasiado para algunos es casi
como si se entrara en una secta con él
siempre he usado sus prendas durante los
últimos 20 años algo en lo que hace me
conmueve es tan único
[Música]
porque puede ser demasiado etapas
o divisiva consideran que las prendas
son muy difíciles de usar los vestidos
por ejemplo por todo el resto bueno creo
que el trabajo de los diseñadores es ir
un poco más allá y eso es lo que hace al
final de sus shows siempre estoy al
borde de las lágrimas
a sus 76 años yohji yamamoto es más
cuidadoso que nunca sus prendas de
siluetas fluidas e innovadoras lo
demuestran la elección entre street wear
y drapeado será difícil
[Música]